you know what i was reading the reviews
of this morning actually i think was uh
good morning the mgk movie
oh yeah did you see that no like the
trailer for it or anything i think i saw
like three seconds of the trailer it's
like a stoner comedy yeah that he wrote
i think with maybe mod son or something
like that yeah you're a clone yeah
yeah
brother that's your brother yeah openly
yeah just your next youtube video you
should just look to camera be like yo by
the way guys go support my brother's new
movie
good morning don't know why you didn't
ask me to be in a scene but it's cool
it's cool you had to do your thing
[Music]
my name is london clash i'm an actor on
the show called good bad
people this is apple
[Music]
come on man
my name is london clash and this is
apple this is a tick tock sound bro
any movie that features text bubbles is
bad no and when they're not realistic
yep like what app is this yeah
there's not a single app ever that looks
like this that's cool why would you make
it like this
it's cool that she's english too good
morning
morning title of the
movie oh it's good oh like
[Music]
in the words of teddy ray
you are 36.
i think apple's breaking up with me
a boy is in trouble this is how we fix
it do they really
oh good for gator man he's he's in this
did they really use the three stooges
like triple head stack right there can
we just get a frame on that that's me on
the bot that's my brother on the bottom
my blood brother
i know yeah i know people have been
saying that forever
[Music]
you're an idiot hope you find your
girlfriend
this is the worst day of my life yo
do you want to be in love or do you want
to be the biggest star in the world
it's time
[Applause]
what is this dust that's people man
[Applause]
i mean can i just say real quick yeah my
first impression after watching the
trailer
star studded
yeah a lot of celebrities yeah in that
movie i have no idea what this movie's
about it's a stoner comedy dude yeah
because they knocked over a urn does it
have to be about anything
yeah no you're right you're supposed to
get high and watch it yeah yeah let's
smoke weed
and just fill in the gaps yes yeah let's
see some of the reviews go to the
audience reviews for it zero percent
versus 78 percent audience hey you know
78 audience girls well i think on imdb
it's like a 2.8 or something this is
from jamie w worst movie i've ever seen
i have seen 1 000 plus movies
that's awesome now trust me i watch
[ __ ] movies all right
no i i actually celebrated a thousand
films with this one and
this one sucked
it was a mid comedy movie but the end
like like after the creds i thought was
genius and epic
[Music]
see look at this it's either five or one
gave it a five because it made me laugh
laugh laugh silly and fun movie to watch
even if it doesn't have any true meaning
of whatever and then the next review is
i did not expect much from this but it
failed to even give that
the plot is slow and boring the majority
of the characters are unlikable and
unfunny i was hoping for a friday
or a super bad but it just sort of just
sucks i'm sorry man
did you think before you wrote that
sentence i was expecting friday from
machine gun kelly
yeah no i was expecting um [ __ ] ice
cube and
uh
chris tucker at the [ __ ]
beginnings of their career
very disappointing oh here we go isn't
it funny it's it's just alternates we're
not reading all this oh damn see ya no
just scroll past let me dig no i think
we should i think we should read it
okay very disappointing i really wanted
to like it
because i really like mgk but just know
the movie has so many plot holes it's
infuriating his friends are the actual
worst
it makes me feel sad for mgk if that's
his definition of best friends
oh my god and i don't understand why
megan fox's character is supposed to
hate him but is the only one who seems
to actually be nice to him and help him
the whole movie centers on him getting a
weird text from his girlfriend and then
can we zoom in on this i feel like i'm
having an aneurism and then not being
able to reach her since his phone gets
soaked with water what he asked his
friends if anyone has her number and no
one does the whole time i'm thinking why
not just contact her through facebook or
instagram exactly and then later in the
movie they start stalking her through
instagram and all his friends seem to
follow her it makes no sense no sense
not to mention he's supposed to be madly
in love with his girlfriend but somehow
their relationship is so rocky that one
weird text makes them think they're
broken up yeah
so many questions
this type of movie has done been done
many times like euro trip days and
confused and harold and kumar but this
is by far the worst attempt with zero
comedy and plot line uh filled with
holes
damn
then this plotline is getting me turned
on seriously so many holes so many holes
filled with holes [ __ ] plot lines i
need to be free filled yeah
are you a plotline plot hole you mean no
are you a plotline because you just keep
showing me holes
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
i swear to god you're just a bad plot
line the way you show me all these holes
looking freak little plotline and i'm a
writer i can punch that [ __ ] up for you
if you want call me right away i'm gonna
plug up your [ __ ] plot holes let me
plug those holes uh you're such a bad
plot line
[Music]
can be your supporting character
just thinking about two writing nerds in
college now um i'm gonna fill your gap
like i would have added five pages to
the count of monte cristo
to better explain the relics and the
role in the film
oh you're so daring that's so crazy
you're so good
that's a good bet thanks dude
that is this is funny
now i'm just picturing some [ __ ]
super chat dude like you would not
expect to be like a movie buff
just
a little girl lays on her back gets
naked she's like he's like damn shit's
giving good morning
he was like what
hella holes in you
[Laughter]
that's all i see is holes
[Applause]
damn turn me into shiloh buff right now
there we go
just call me stanley yell now that's
real quick
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
what's my name backwards stanley no dude
it's yvonne it's my name is dave stupid
[Laughter]
yeah
let me stella stanley on there
[Laughter]
that's a bar
that's one hole
i just want oh man
you